[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily it is a blatant
attempt
to kill george floyd a second
time yes a special hearing for the four
former officers
charged in the death of george floyd we
break down important arguments
filed in court and two deputies who were
ambushed
by a gunman in a cowardly fashion the
search is on for the suspect
accused of shooting two los angeles
county deputies
plus when it all added up i went wow a
jury delivers a nearly 100 million
dollar verdict
after officials returned two children to
the father suspected
of making their mother disappear they
cannot ignore
this award they're going to have to
address the issues
an exclusive interview with the
children's grandparents who scored the
victory
is straight ahead on law and crime daily
where we cover court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
and welcome everyone i'm erin keller
along with brian buckfire and terry
austin
a minneapolis judge must decide a series
of key arguments
that will have serious impacts on the
trial of four former officers
accused of playing a role in the alleged
murder of george floyd
the officers are arguing at this early
point in the case
that their actions were justified when
they put
floyd into a police suv after a nearby
store owner
accused floyd of trying to pass fake
cash floyd's friend said he was
terrified after having been shot by the
police in the past
and the struggle ended with all four
officers holding floyd to the ground he
died shortly later
protesters gathered outside the
courthouse laying on the ground in honor
of george floyd
they want the trial to remain in the
twin cities not move to some far away
county
we demand that these trials stay here
where they have to face the wrath
of the communities they have terrorized
as for the upward sentencing guidelines
called for by the prosecution
bring it on actual murdering cops should
be actually prosecuted
the prosecution has a motion to try
all these cases as one the cops lawyers
are against it
they should all go to prison together
separately whatever it takes
legally here's what the trial hearing
was all about
the state is asking to join all four of
the cases together into one proceeding
to submit
aggravating legal factors to the jury
those can make the punishments more
serious
and for the defense to disclose expert
witnesses
the defense meanwhile is asking for a
change of venue to move the case out of
the twin cities
also asking to sequester the jury for
the eventual trial to disqualify
the local county attorney's office and
to settle evidence
issues involving character this
deals with evidence of so-called other
bad acts and whether they will be
allowed into the proceedings
let's start with the topic of change of
venue terry i want you to listen to how
an attorney for george floyd's family
argued against the officer's attempt
to move the trial to another part of the
state
the only goal they have
in trying to change venues is to get as
many
jurors as possible who do not look like
george floyd
they don't want jurors that look like
you no they do not
okay terry so the constitutional
principle here is that every defendant
has a right to a local jury of his peers
that's the defendant's right the
defendant can waive it
can the state successfully force this
trial to stay where the advocates want
it to say in the twin cities
well here's what i think aaron i think
the officers want to move the trial out
of hennepin county because they're
trying to say
the pre-trial publicity is going to
affect the trial and in fact we know
there's a sixth amendment right to
a criminal defendant's right to a public
trial
in a county where it occurred but the
judge has already indicated that they
should try to find a suitable jury in
hennepin county
before considering changing the location
and actually i think that makes a lot of
sense because if you think about it
there's no way that you can get a jury
who has not heard about this case
you can't escape the publicity in this
one so brian these defendants want
separate trials but the state
wants to try everybody together because
the process would be easier
should the cases be split it depends on
what you're asking as a defense attorney
i wouldn't say want i always say
need especially if you're tao king or
elaine's defense attorneys you need to
separate these cases from showing
because chauvin
is the probably the worst of the bad
apples here and you cannot try that case
together with them
however they're making very weak
arguments to do that they're not even
trying to point the finger at each other
by making an antagonistic defense
that would have been the golden egg for
separation but they're not doing it here
defense attorneys for ex-cop j alexander
king are asking a judge to dismiss the
charges claiming george floyd died
of a drug overdose the medical examiner
said floyd had fentanyl in his system
and had recently taken methamphetamine
an attorney for floyd's family pointed
to the emmy's
listed manner of death homicide
there is no doubt that he died from
mechanical exposition
they want to coincidentally say that
whatever drugs were in his system
killed him at the same time that the
knee on the neck and the pressure on his
back killed them
and that's the falsity of this so when
you look at this from a legal
perspective
the causation perspective those drugs
did
nothing to him because we know that he
had situational awareness
he was cooperative he was begging to do
what we all are doing as a matter of
right
and that is breathing he wanted an
oxygen exchange between his brain
and his lungs and he was denied that
when he asked
please may i breathe that
that drug defense is desperate it will
fail and it's false
that will be disputed in this trial it
seems based on the pre-trial motions
terry
another topic though i want to ask about
some prosecutors been disqualified for
things like speaking to witnesses such
as the medical examiner what's your
reaction to that
well you know i think you have to be
careful when you are prosecuting a case
to make sure you don't
have a conflict of interest by getting
too involved and here
i think the judge dismissed the
prosecutors because they got involved
they went to the medical exam and the
autopsy and that was just too close for
comfort
they may be witnesses may be
disqualified brian another topic here so
many topics in this pre-trial
hearing that we're covering the judge
ruled that george floyd's
record from texas will not come in to
the upcoming trials of the four
officers now that seems wise to me from
a relevance perspective do you agree
absolutely it's too abstract of course
whenever you have any case
as a defense attorney you want to try to
cut create any kind of doubt or any kind
of reason
as to why the officers use force against
the victim or the alleged
victim in this case but if you're going
to go back to a different state years
before any of these officers knew him or
any kind of basis
to understand what his background was
it's irrelevant it's prejudicial and it
shouldn't come in
and terry that core issue here of the
actual cause and manner of death
why litigate that i mean i know that i
guess you have to as a defense attorney
brian you're shaking your head okay so
i'll go to you why litigate it so many
people
saw the video a lot of people would say
look the drugs in the system irrelevant
it's don't litigate it now because
that is going to create a dead end at
trial maybe you can spring it on the
prosecutor that's one of the best
strengths that we have defense attorneys
have
we can spring upon the reasonable doubt
at trial but if you do it this far in
advance
that's that's out the window it's gone
as an argument okay terry do you agree
is now the wrong time to do that
this is what i think i think that the
medical report is going to be critical
and that the witnesses at trial the
experts
are going to be key to this case because
it all depends on what
caused the death of george floyd and
still ahead here on law and crime daily
a reward for the suspect accused of
ambushing two los angeles county
sheriff's deputies
has anybody seen this man
we begged them not to let them go to
that last visitation
and then they're gone and later in the
broadcast our exclusive interview with
the parents of a mother who's presumed
murder at the hands of her husband
was not enough to stop social services
workers from sending her own children
right back into harm's way
[Music]
two los angeles county sheriff's
deputies are out of surgery after being
shot and critically injured
in what authorities are calling an
ambush the sheriff's department is
offering a 100 thousand dollar reward
for information leading to the arrest of
the suspect
seen here in surveillance video which
authorities say shows the shootings of
two deputies
sitting in a vehicle around seven
o'clock saturday evening here's how the
authorities
described that suspect the suspect
approached them from behind
as the deputies were facing southbound
in their patrol vehicle
suspect came from the north he walked
along the passenger side of the car
he acted as if he was going to walk past
the car and then he
made a left turn directly toward the car
raised a pistol
and fired several rounds inside of the
vehicle striking both of the
sheriff's deputies
the suspect then fled on foot northbound
from the shooting scene
and out of view the deputies radioed for
help
assisting units from the district
responded
and transported both those deputies here
to saint francis medical center
where they're being treated i can tell
you at this point we have a very
very uh generic suspect description of a
dark-skinned male
and that came from one of the deputies
one of the victims
the two deputies were rushed into
surgery after radioing for help for
themselves
the sheriff's office tweeted at
protesters yelling
we hope they die outside the hospital
telling them not to block the entrance
the tweet
has since been deleted well they're both
suffering from multiple gunshot wounds
they're out of surgery right now so
we're going to keep them in our thoughts
and prayers
one is a 31 year old mother of
a six-year-old boy her husband is here
with them the other one is a 24 year old
and parents are here girlfriend is here
they're both out of class 437 so they
just graduated and i fact i swore them
into office just 14 months ago
these are real people doing a tough job
and
it just shows just the dangers of the
job
in the blink of an eye terry and brian
back for some analysis now brian let's
assume this case goes to trial it looks
like prosecutors have an attempted first
degree murder charge because the suspect
was allegedly lying in weight and
committed a premeditated crime and
there's other reasons like a special law
in california
that ups the charge basically if the
victim is a peace officer
again assuming this case goes to trial
because we have to find the suspect and
he has to make it to court so
assuming those two parts happen this
person is looking at a monster of a hill
of trial against him
this is not something the prosecutor is
going to offer a deal to they're going
to be asking for
the highest punishment of life because
this
i i'm all for protesting i'm all for
good trouble as john lewis called it but
this is not it and this is
disgusting i think just about everybody
agrees with that terry i think you agree
as well
got another question though terry these
people outside the hospital are
basically saying they want the officers
to die could those people potentially be
charged
if we're taking a bar exam look at
things i guess
well they have the right to say that
although obviously it's a horrible thing
to wish that upon anyone
but they don't have a right to block the
interest or to obstruct the police
or not to obey the police and as in fact
they can be charged with
obstruction or resisting arrest there's
even a charge called contempt
of police officer for not obeying the
police officers so you can get in
trouble for that
brian real quick i think you were
thinking potential disorderly conduct as
well
yeah if you want to get really creative
you can get disorderly conduct you can
stretch it i don't think it would
stick but maybe also reckless
endangerment because people need to get
in and out of that area
for life-saving surgeries and coming up
next right here on law and crime daily
he always complained and he always
ranted
and always broke the rules
so why did authorities give such a
father a visitation which led to the
murder of his two children
our exclusive interview with the
grandparents is straight ahead
and now to a record judgment against the
washington state department of social
and health services for returning two
boys to a
father suspected by many of playing a
role
in the death of their mother susan
powell disappeared in december 2009 her
husband
josh claimed he took their two children
on a midnight camping trip
in sub-zero temperatures when susan
disappeared
and he maintained his innocence in her
disappearance in 2012
josh locked a social services worker out
of his home during a supervised visit
killed his children with a hatchet and
killed himself by setting
fire to the home the grandparents of
those children sued the department of
social services and won
98 million dollars they recently opened
up to me about the case
and the verdict the main thing i heard
was the verdict that they were guilty
of uh negligence that was the important
part
and then the number was they didn't say
98 million they said 45 million or
something which
i thought but that was as they were
breaking it down so i thought well
well that doesn't very much but then
when it all added up i went
wow uh they cannot ignore this
award they can't just you know pay it
out of petty cash or something and be
done with it they're going to have to
address the issues
and that's ultimately the hope here is
that the state will really look into
this and try to prevent this from
happening to any other family
yeah absolutely as we went through the
entire trial
their witnesses for the state which was
their
employees they admitted all throughout
that
they did not follow the proper policy
guidelines for dealing with domestic
violence even with the issue and dealing
with the situation
and uh i could not believe that they
thought they were somewhere
making progress in the case but they
went on through
and uh it was a clear
the the amount of negligence the amount
of
incompetence at all levels of
supervisors on up in dshs was clearly
made
presented to the jury and to the world
during that trial attorneys for those
grandparents asked for five million
dollars for each minute
each of those children suffered
unfortunately the only way that we can
render justice in a situation like this
is through the awarding of money
money damages are the only choice
and so i put it to you this way
we consider what the obligations of the
state were
we consider what options they have
available
we consider what they recognize the
risks to be
consider what they actually did
and we consider the result this
incredible miserable and
this state argued unsuccessfully that
its case workers
had done enough it's very difficult to
show potential risk
in these situations where you might
think something is going to happen
but you don't have enough proof to
remove a child
it actually takes facts and proof to
remove a child
from their parent to keep them out of
the home
you can feel like there is risk or you
can sense there is risk
but gut feelings don't count charlie and
braden
and really specifically charlie continue
to press i want to go home to my father
it was evident that those boys love
their father
and when we come back more from the
parents of crime victim susan powell
why they took the step of suing the
state and why the law was
ultimately on their side that's when we
return on lawn crime
[Music]
daily
we're back with more from the parents of
susan powell whose husband was suspected
of killing her
and who later him killed himself and the
couple's children
susan's parents charles and judy cox
told me recently about why they chose
the long and difficult path of
litigation
i generally originally thought well
these were
civil servants overworked and underpaid
and
whatever limited resources that but then
when we found out
that they had basically plotted and
conspired to uh
get the children back with josh they
basically were
negligent of doing the job that they
were paid to do
child protective services they weren't
protecting the children i felt
this has to stop and this has to be
we have to do something to expose the
negligence and the
the lack of knowledge of the people in
charge
for them to say that's not domestic
violence when you you are
the only suspect in your wife's
disappearance
and award custody through killing your
spouse
or getting rid of your spouse is just
ludicrous
just it makes absolutely no sense at all
and these are supposed to be people with
psychologists
and social workers uh training and
understand domestic violence and dealing
with difficult people and all like that
and
we were let down completely the powell's
attorneys told me they expect the full
98 million dollar award to come out of
the state's coffers
the jury determined that the state
breached its duty to protect the powell
children
and open and shut negligence case we
believe
that if this is an absolutely
unassailable number the evidence
supports the number
the state did not argue against the
damage calculation or suggestions that
were made at trial
and we don't have caps in washington in
cases like this so
there's we don't have like you see in
california other jurisdictions where
there'd be certain caps like medical
malpractice cases
etc we don't have that in washington
state we don't have punitive damages in
this state so this award was based upon
conscious pain and suffering and damages
of those kids
the jurors found that they suffered
greatly for
a great amount of time and that is very
painful to think
about obviously it's excruciating to
think about but on the other hand that
the jurors recognized that pain
and decided that the state was
responsible for that pain
was also gratifying because we hope that
it gets
a note across that they need to follow
their protocol
so this kind of pain and suffering
doesn't happen again
charles and judy cox say they plan to
earmark their record verdict towards
advocacy including legal assistance
and housing assistance for women like
their daughter who had to leave abusive
relationships
it's not over yet but but
the jury verdict was very
comforting and a clear vindication of
our stand and what we found and
improved that we did prove in a court of
law that they were negligent
and tomorrow on law and crime daily
charles and judy share their thoughts on
exactly what
happened to their daughter and who else
might have been involved
terry you worked in a government law
department how might
agencies be handling that type of
verdict
not very well aaron but let's hope this
is a wake-up call for the agency
to make changes so we won't see this
kind of incident happen again
and in some states brian there's a cap
on damage awards like that so in some
states
a jury might say 98 million and the
plaintiffs might get just a tiny
fraction of that
exactly it's gonna be interesting to see
how this plays out again we're hearing
their lawyers talk about how that's
gonna be distributed and i think the
family has a great idea as to how that
money can help
uh people in the greater community
certainly great analysis here on law and
crime daily from both of our experts
we appreciate you joining us thanks for
being here along with us for everything
we'll see you right here tomorrow for
our coverage of the day in court
on law and crime daily
[Music]
[Music]
you